[Musique]
après cilaos bras panon et saint-leu 7 à
saint pierre que le président du
département cyrille melchior s'est rendu
ce lundi 15 novembre moment fort de la
visite la signature du pacte de
solidarité deuxième génération qui s'est
déroulée à la mairie annexe de la ligne
paradis rénovée dans le cadre du pst un
plus de 7 millions d'euros seront
alloués à la capitale du sud cette pièce
est une commune comme l'a dit le maire
qui se développe dans la population
n'arrête pas d'augmenter et bien
évidemment c'est un pierre comme
d'autres communes rencontrent des
difficultés sociales avec un taux de
chômage élevé des jeunes en grande
difficulté des familles qui mérite
d'être accompagné et donc le pst deux
que nous avons signé ma c'est une façon
de dire que le département accompagne
cette belle commune dans son
développement accompagne cette belle
commune en terme de solidarité pour les
plus vulnérables et
cette somme sera louée permirent de
trois ans cyril nous a toujours
accompagné un bon aujourd'hui nous avons
pas littéralement à niveau à chaque fois
que la collectivité c'est pur hasard
besoin de cyril belchior cire elle a
répondu présent nous avons des dossiers
de proximité voyez vous y implanter des
index un cyber base ou bibliothèque
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de projets
et beaucoup de réalisations le pense
pendant cette mandature
autre rendez vous majeur l'inauguration
du chemin stéphane avec un trafic de
plus de 8 500 véhicules par jour ces
travaux était très attendu dans l'un il
ya une dame qui vive lundi 6 à 0 puis ça
venu stéphane quasiment parce que
maintenant il ya d'éclairage et à la
route il ya un peu plus de sécurité même
si peut-être dire à son enfant elle peut
refaire mais au moins ça a été un milieu
et ça c'est un bel exemple
le président et le maire ont également
visité un chantier à cia terre sainte
mise en oeuvre par l'association alisée
du cap les élus ont planté avec des
enfants de l'école edith piaf plusieurs
espèces adaptées au milieu dans le cadre
du plan un million d'art et ça ce sont
des enfants qui plante en paraît bien
sûr par des adultes
le volet social n'a pas été oubliée
cyril même coeur et michel fontaine ont
visité une famille en bénéficier du
dispositif d'amélioration de l'habitat a
master
[Musique]